tu vas faire vacciner ici quand ils ont
et quand ils pourront tout le monde
maintenant je n'ai pas le choix couasnon
qu'on l'ait j'ai déjà eu donc c'est
alors on veut la voir plusieurs faudrait
revoir plusieurs fois un bon bah c'est
comme le permis enfin je vais pas dans
le père noël a fait deux fois pernikoff
a bien sûr j'irai me faire avec ses
arrêts merci c'est pas la peine de faire
cet été ça mais je ne me pose même pas
la question je pense que ça se passe on
peut bien sûr tout de suite delphine non
à l'a dit non non elle ne marche pas non
mon chéri envie de se faire vacciner
mercredi et jeudi au caire la non mais
sans déconner ouais mais moi je lui
demande lui demande d'attendre moi je ne
sais pas quoi vous n'êtes pas chaude
j'avais peur qu'il est un que truc qui
s'épousent genre ça en fait on sait pas
il ya toujours des des retours sur les
vaccins c'est ça le problème quoi et
aujourd'hui on n'a pas assez de temps
pour qu'ils aient leur tour donc bah
diallo vous faire vacciner vous j'ai
très peur mais je pense que je le ferais
ne serait ce que pour protéger ma mère
donc je pense que je le ferais mais j'ai
très peur et bon voila j'ai regardé non
je ne sens pas moi j'ai encore un peu
besoin je vois pas ce qui peut vous
arriver de pire je suis pas rassuré
encore là ouais ça dépend quel vaccin
j'ai un peu peur des effets secondaires
non je suis pas rassuré montus elle bien
sûr or moi je veux accuser directement
revanche comme je suis un des plus vieux
ici je serai vacciner avant vous tous
ouais ouais au mois de mars début mars
dès mars à vacciner ben oui bah
profitez-en pour prendre leur asthme
trois mois de congé ont proposé de faire
du bien tabou qu'est lives et dvd vous à
vous faire vacciner ce match les jours
comme le gouvernement et vous
moi je suis pas très chaud on n'aura pas
le choix a priori je pense que si on
veut voyager si on va aller au resto on
va nous demander d'être vacciné donc si
on veut revivre normalement on devrait
être vaccinée d'accord alors justement
pour lutter contre la copie des
scientifiques préconisent l'utilisation
de gestes barrières et en matière
d'activité sexuelle
je dis ça pour vous daniel parce que
c'est que voilà il recommande également
quelque chose d'assez surprenant au
regard des états unis le département de
la santé publique de new york recommande
pour éviter la contagion de se masturber
leur credo vous êtes votre partenaire
sexuel le plus sur la masturbation ne
propagent pas le coc vide surtout si
vous vous lavez les mains et les
sex-toys à l'eau et au savon pendant au
moins
vingt secondes avant et après je
voudrais juste vous dire un truc pendant
le sujet il ya nicolas pernikoff café
yes est ce que vous savez pourquoi parce
que ça stimule les globules blancs et
vraisemblablement s'avoue protégerait
lors de l'éjaculation ça vous protège
les biens au sahara c'est surtout pour
pas faire l'amour en vrai oui à personne
mais c'est le sortiront peut plus voir
ses amis on peut plus faire l'amour
c'est quoi le projet en fait on doit
être isolé confiné dans sa chambre en
visioconférence avec un masque à se
masturber ça te fait quoi de mal